[Music]
Chinese firms fully or partly own and
operate all these ports outside China's
borders there's 95 of them on this map
meanwhile U.S companies don't operate
any major ports abroad for China these
ports have been part of a long-term
effort to build Global infrastructure
Chinese firms have spent years and
billions of dollars to build operate and
develop ports around the world American
officials view China's expanding Network
as an increasing security threat posing
significant economic and even military
risks so what has the U.S done to
counter this block China from making
more deals to keep ports and so-called
friendly hands but the U.S has had mixed
success
[Music]
in the past decade China has spent a
trillion dollars on its belt and Road
initiative a global infrastructure
project designed to boost China's
economy and political clout through
government-backed investments in dozens
of countries the scale of China's
trading Enterprise is really staggering
Isaac Cardin is a senior fellow at the
Carnegie endowment studying China's
Maritime Affairs he and a colleague
spent years building a data set of all
chinese-owned and operated ports around
the world it currently includes 95 ports
across dozens of countries the Strategic
motivations for China I think are
fundamentally defensive they feel
vulnerable to the United States and its
Alliance Network that they could be cut
out of the global economic system in
some fundamental way and so I think the
drive to make themselves indispensable
to it and Central to it is in part a way
of insulating themselves against that
vulnerability ports are considered
National Security infrastructure by the
US government because there's some
Central to the flow of essential Goods
like steel and food
commercial ports are Dual Purpose
they're useful both economically China
can give its vessels priority handling
and lower docking fees and militarily
docs are used by navies to refuel
restock and rearm ships in recent years
the US has worked to keep China from
expanding this network in a few
strategic regions
China has three main shipping and
logistics companies that own most of its
stakes in overseas ports Costco shipping
ports China Merchants port and
Hutchinson ports Costco and China
Merchants are both owned by China's
central government while Hutcherson is
privately owned Costco is an investor in
several key U.S ports Los Angeles Long
Beach and Seattle
but in 2017 when Costco almost took over
operation of a Long Beach Container
Terminal U.S Regulators stepped in the
Trump Administration blocked them from
getting control out of National Security
concerns ultimately Costco sold the
terminal
but Chinese firms are still a major
Presence at U.S ports Costco still has a
major stake in another Container
Terminal at Long Beach from a
pre-existing deal and lots of Port
infrastructure like the cranes that move
cargo from ship to shore is made in
China lately some U.S officials have
argued that's a security concern too
there's growing suspicion that anything
which is controlled by China is used to
spy in the United States this has been
procedures at the U.S government to see
whether the cranes at American ports
which are made in China are used to spy
on the operations of the port in Europe
the U.S has also been trying to block
China from expanding its stake in ports
and controlling the flow of goods to the
continent but U.S officials have had
mixed success convincing countries that
security concerns outweigh the benefits
of Chinese State investment in Hamburg
Germany's largest port Costco planned to
buy a 35 stake in one of the port's
container terminals government officials
reduce the potential stake to 24.9
percent but still faced criticism from
the U.S and many in the German
government the country's Chancellor
ultimately permitted the deal to move
forward but the offer is still pending
review
the United States would advise and press
any country in the world not to accept
Chinese Investments it's a big dilemma
for countries because the Chinese have
the cash to invest which means this
creates a lot of jobs and it also
improves the outputs of those countries
the Hamburg deal though continues to
face optician which will which will make
it difficult
in the past
such small investment wouldn't even make
news it's just indicative of how tense
the relations of the Warsaw world are
with Beijing a similar scene played out
in Croatia but in that case the US was
more successful it used behind the
scenes diplomacy to have Croatia cancel
a deal it had made with Chinese firms
looking to operate a Container Terminal
in rieca and give the contract to a
Danish company mayersk instead ryaka is
strategically valuable because it's
close to the Suez Canal and has access
to central European markets the U.S
government was particularly concerned
about the deal because the U.S Navy and
NATO sometimes used the port to move
military equipment in and out of Europe
China could have made that more
difficult what western intelligence
officials are saying is that by
controlling this serve those they could
eventually have a Nave installation
there in the future I don't think this
will be the case especially in any
European point in time soon but it could
happen in Africa the U.S has
arrangements with dozens of military
bases in Africa including several on the
continents west north and east coasts
China has just one base in Djibouti
but while U.S firms don't own commercial
ports in Africa Chinese firms own many
U.S officials have been concerned about
China building on the relationships it's
formed through commercial ports to
establish additional permanent military
bases in Africa especially on the
Atlantic ocean waters the U.S considers
home turf the thing I think I'm most
worried about is this military base on
the Atlantic Coast and where they have
the most traction for that today is an
Equatorial Guinea in Equatorial Guinea
the U.S has been trying to convince
country officials to reject China's bid
to build a military base in the city of
Bata where China already has a
commercial Port deep enough for Naval
vessels to dock it's easy to put explore
Naval facility at a commercial Port if
the port infrastructure is there it can
be used by a Navy ship there are
I think real concerns that eventually
you will see Chinese warships docking at
that Port if it were to establish a
military base there Equatorial Guinea
would be China's first base on the
Atlantic which would enable Chinese
warships to re-arm opposite the east
coast of the U.S U.S officials have gone
to Equatorial Guinea to persuade leaders
there to reject China's overtures but
it's unclear whether the Diplomatic
Outreach will fend off a Chinese Naval
presence there this will be something
that U.S officials are watching closely
Beijing hopes that it could in the
future have a military presence in
terminals reports that it controls
whether it is or isn't defensive is
almost irrelevant it has security
consequences we need to be attuned to
those we need to focus on what we're
trying to accomplish and maybe that
means we do need to counter China at
various turns but that can't petition is
not going to be one for one you get a
port we get a port it's more like what
can we do to secure our own Maritime
trade and transport because ultimately
that's what they're doing it just has
negative externalities for our own
ability to feel secure in Maritime trade